bon forme ce jeudi 8 octobre merci de
nous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal on commence se
jeter avec les titres de votre actualité
locale salaires chômage protection
sociale retraite quelques unes des
raisons à la grève d'aujourd'hui dans le
secteur public mais aussi dans une
partie du privé nous faisons le point
sur les revendications mais aussi sur
les perturbations
le ps organisera dans quelques jours un
référendum pour déterminer si ces
électeurs sont résolus à l'union pour
les régionales de décembre comment se
passe l'organisation et surtout quelles
conséquences attendues en plateau à une
amap candidat dans les yvelines sur la
liste socialiste aux les jusqu'au 11
octobre se déroule la fête de la science
partager des savoirs et mieux
appréhender le monde qui nous entoure
c'est l'objectif de ce rendez vous
annuel des animations proposées à
travers toute la france
le point sur notre secteur avec marie
laure et signèrent de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines et annabelle
doazit de l'observatoire de versailles
50 ans et je vous le disais en titre
plusieurs organisations syndicales ont
appelé à la mobilisation aujourd'hui du
côté des transports pas de grosses
perturbations en ile de france dans les
yvelines du côté des écoles
le mouvement a été peu suivi ciel dans
l'académie de versailles le rectorat
dénombre moins de 1% de grévistes dans
les collèges mais aussi les lycées et le
premier degré donc le primaire et les
syndicats cgt fsu et solidaires ont
appelé à une mobilisation nationale des
salariés du public et du privé
aujourd'hui les organisateurs veulent
alerter les autorités sur la situation
économique et social jugées non
satisfaisante selon eux dans les
yvelines cheminots salariés du secteur
de la santé action sociale et
collectivités territoriales se sont
réunis sur différents lieux avant de
rejoindre le gland le grand
rassemblement de paris william elle pour
ce reportage lui tant que la sncf le
reconnaissent et les embauches alors
juste malheureux
ce matin à versailles des cheminots ont
répondu présent à l'appel à la
mobilisation générale lancé par les
différents syndicats cgt fsu et
solidaires de nous devant la gare de
versailles chantiers pour manifester
contre les conditions de travail qui
selon eux se dégradent gp également
rejoint par le mouvement des
travailleurs sans papiers du 68
on veut faire des économies sur le dos
des cheminots mais aussi son dos des
usagers
parce que ces deux gares fermées c'est
des gares et des trains qui sont
déshumanisées c'est des postes supprimés
ces mêmes des trains supprimés par
manque de personnel aujourd'hui c'est la
situation du service public ferroviaire
sur la région parisienne mais aussi
parce que beaucoup de ces gens là
beaucoup de ces sans-papiers qui sont
les invisibles qui font tourner le pays
mais aussi qui font tourner le soin de
faire beaucoup nettoie les gars ici
beaucoup de pose des rails ici à la sncf
fait comme si de rien n'était et elle
s'en lave les mains
tous des travailleurs des secteurs
public et privé étaient appelés à se
rassembler à paris aujourd'hui toujours
à versailles avant leur départ pour la
mobilisation nationale les agents de la
ville se sont regroupés devant la mairie
dénoncent une surcharge de travail et le
manque de sécurité
on a beaucoup de personnes en dépression
on a eu des tentatives de suicide
on a des agents qui agresse d'autres des
supérieurs concrètement on demande du
respect pour le personnel on demande à
ce que le personnel soit écoutée on
demande des effectifs des meilleures
conditions de travail
plusieurs rassemblements étaient
organisés dans les yvelines les salariés
de la macif et du secteur automobile ou
encore de la cpam ont manifesté dans le
département après avoir fait valoir nos
revendications au niveau local tous ont
rejoint la place de la république à
paris pour l'appel à la mobilisation
nationale avec la sphère des syndicats
air france et le mouvement de grève
d'aujourd'hui nous vous avons demandé à
vous saint quentinois ce que vous
pensiez du climat social actuel regarder
les gens sont moroses etc
on sait pas trop bas au nouveau climat
social que ce soit toutes entreprises
confondues finalement la nuit et et du
rejet l'accril en ce moment un montant
bon que je suis un gouvernement
les pompes qui peuvent enfin ils font
pas tout avec tout ce qui se passe
les migrants nadine morano
enfin etc etc tout ça je trouve que
c'est déplorable faut que la france se
remettent à nous les français se
remettent en cause aussi donc je sens
qu'il ya beaucoup à faire
c'est particulièrement détestable et ben
faut rester optimiste espérait que ça
ira mieux
halima match voyait notamment réagir par
rapport à ce sujet justement la garde et
la médiation c'est un sujet qui touche
également le gouvernement le ps
oui oui c'est c'est aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que il y à un certain nombre de
revendications la grèce
la grève a pas été très très suivis en
temps il faut entendre un certain nombre
de revendications qui sont qui sont leur
soient les conditions de travail sur la
question des rémunérations des primes
mais bon c'est un dialogue continu c'est
pas on peut pas avancer par un coup on
faisait un peu référence dans votre
reportage à la question de air france et
c'est vrai que ces deux mois il est
arrivé un petit peu d'avancé un peu par
à coups et je pense que le dialogue
social devrait être beaucoup plus
homogène beaucoup plus continue dans le
temps avec les avec les salariés la
direction pour pouvoir trouver des
solutions nous sommes justement en ligne
avec mathieu bolle-reddat secrétaire
général cgt des cheminots de versailles
mathieu leur aider à la mobilisation a
finalement été assez peu suivie
votre appel n'a pas été entendu qu'en
pensez vous alors je suis oui ça fait
pas tellement ce qu'elle pense pas
qu'ils aient des entreprises dans quels
cas été suivis vestiges de s'y retrouver
parmi nous sur un rassemblement
important sur la base de revendications
locales contre les suppressions de
postes contre les fermetures de gares
qui présentera la déshumanisation des
gares et des princes bon voilà alors
effectivement le mouvement est général
le mouvement social générale en france
plutôt compliqué en ce moment c'est pas
facile mais il ya il ya beaucoup
d'attaqués contre va contre des
travailleurs un certain nombre
d'entreprises
il n'y a pas donné les postes dans les
bus air france il ya du before you
really à bientôt et d'autres actions
sont prévues voulions pas de vue
en général il y aura d'autres
mobilisations comme celle ci est
d'ampleur nationale avec un appel à tous
les salariés privés publics qui seront
lancés prochainement savez dieu et son
organisation était fait et on discute
non rappelle hors-sol d'en haut comme un
général d'armée observons tous les
salariés des besoins du sérail et
d'édith des salariés aujourd'hui ariane
beaucoup de problèmes et beaucoup de
situations explosives
par contre l'entreprise de façon à paris
ou en région et ce qu'il ment il ya une
demande forte de battre mobilisation sur
l'hospitalité saint-henri transports ce
soit public ou privé n'y a pas
aujourd'hui un jour qui passe dans le
pays entier accord commercial où il ya
des grèves à la restauration rapide à
l'hôpital qui luttent contre la
fermeture
merci mathieu molé reda pour ces
précisions précision par dont nous
suivrons un ensemble votre actualité et
la communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines a débuté hier soir
les réunions publiques pour informer les
saint quentinois du plui le plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal le plan
définitif sera présenté aux élus au mois
de décembre la première réunion réunion
concernait la commune de la verrière
explications avec mélanie poké nouvelle
étape dans l'élaboration du pl lui
débuter en 2013 par la communauté
d'agglomération
ce document d'urbanisme doit permettre
d'étudier les possibilités d'évolution
du territoire à l'échelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en fonction
des questions du public en fonction des
orientations qui nous disent en fonction
des problématiques qui font remonter
effectivement on sera peut-être amené à
modifier le projet on a travaillé pour
le moment
à partir des documents qui existe
aujourd'hui on a travaillé aussi avec
l'ensemble des équipes municipales de
l'agglomération mais sur la phase
réglementaire on n'a pas encore
travaillé avec les habitants ces
réunions sa compagne dans chaque commune
d'exposition évolutive avec une urne
permettant aux saint quentinois de
s'exprimer le projet sera présenté aux
élus de la casse qui au mois de décembre
le ps glee devrait être arrêtée et
complètement approuvée en conseil
communautaire à l'automne ou en fin
d'année en fin d'année prochaine pour
être applicable dès début 2010 7,6
autres réunions sont programmées la
prochaine aura lieu le 12 octobre à
elancourt
puis ce sera au tour de guyancourt et de
trappes la dernière réunion se tiendra
le 9 novembre en salle du conseil
communautaire de la casse qui pourrait
changer ou pour duper lui à l'échelle de
l'agglomération et se rend plateau nous
avons trois invités donc marie le reste
anja responsable du rayonnement culturel
pour l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
annabelle doazit chargé des
communications observatoire de
versailles saint quentin
nous parlerons avec vous dans quelques
instants de la fête de la science et
pour commencer ali mohamad vous êtes
candidat parti socialiste aux régionales
et vous allez nous parler du référendum
du parti socialiste il a lieu du 16 au
18 octobre
la question posée donc aux électeurs de
gauche et face à la droite extrême
droite souhaitez-vous l'unité de la
gauche et des écologistes aux élections
régionales alors justement quand ça cela
va s'organiser sur internet
duras des points on pourra voter alors
vous avez vous aurez deux types de vote
donc à un vote sur internet à travers un
site qui va être opérationnel le 16
octobre et on a un certain nombre de
points qui vont s'organiser dans les
yvelines
sur l'ensemble des communes
sur trois jours le 16 le 17 et le 18
octobre donc qui ces points seront
centralisées sur le site internet et les
habitants les citoyens pourront aller
voter en fait alors le référendum cette
décision s'est fait un petit peu
précipitamment si je puis dire ainsi
c'était décidé à la fin du mois de
septembre
pourquoi finalement le faire quelle est
la vraie raison en fait il ya plusieurs
raisons
la première qui s'est aussi un petit peu
pour mettre un peu ingrat choc pour
montrer un peu le danger qui peut y
avoir dans certaines régions où le fn
est très fort la deuxième raison c'est
que aujourd'hui souvent c'est les
appareils qui parle aux appareils
et aujourd'hui quand on regarde un petit
peu les bases militantes en tout cas les
bases d'adhérents des différents partis
les positions sont passés les douaniers
que ça il ya possibilité de trouver des
accords en tout cas des discussions sur
un certain nombre de projets et et
d'avoir des accords ou désaccords et
donc c'était un peu le l'objectif et je
pense que voilà c'est arrivé à ce niveau
là mais il ya un troisième point non non
je pense que le la mobilisation alors
elle sera moins importante que la
mobilisation des primaires il faut pas
il faut pas qu'il faut être clair sur ce
point là en même temps c'est vrai que
les délais d'organisation son cours mais
en même temps le parti socialiste est un
parti organisé et donc on sait faire
face à ce type de situation et on va
pouvoir mobiliser que ce soit auprès
dans les gares les marchés point fixe
partie de la gauche donc les verts le
parti communiste pourtant les réactions
justement de ce côté là haut du moins en
ile-de-france ne sont pas très positives
notamment mené la course et la nationale
d'europe écologie les verts a dit que ce
référendum démontre une forme de panique
non c'est pas en fait la situation en
fonction des régions n'est pas n'est pas
la même sur que la région de la
situation en ile de france et pas du
tout la même que ce que vous avez dans
le nord pas de calais où il ya un risque
fn
regardez la région ile-de-france depuis
plusieurs années pour ce rebond da
le front de gauche europe ecologie les
verts les radicaux les socialistes
gouvernent ensemble et monnaies ont mené
des actions qui ont changé concrètement
la vie des franciliens ont peu parlé
récemment du passe navigo qui est passé
à 60 et d'eau on peut parler de
l'investissement dans les transports qui
a été fait et on peut parler de la
question de la rénovation de la
construction des lycées et gérer toutes
les toute la panoplie de la gauche est
représentée dans l'exécutif régional
donc on a fait des choses ensemble
la situation en ile de france est
beaucoup plus calme beaucoup plus
sereine et nous avons des discussions
très constructives avec nos partenaires
de gauche c'est vrai que la situation
n'est pas la même dans le nord pas de
calais ou en paca où la situation et le
risque au fn est beaucoup plus poussée
et donc c'est vrai que sur gérait les
enjeux en tout cas sur notre région il a
peut-être un peu moins dangereux que ce
qui peut avoir nord pas de calais ce
type de référendum
voilà pour final c'est le ce référendum
est positif il y aura un vrai
rassemblement vous arriverez mettre
d'accord oui vous savez les discussions
avec nos partenaires commencent commencé
avant parce que je pense qu'ils sont
tous conscients que un moment donné ce
qu'on a fait ensemble on l'a bien fait
après au premier tour les électeurs ont
le choix
mais en même temps en face on a quand
même une droite qui est un petit peu
réactionnaire sera 32 points qu'ils
changent d'avis assez assez rapidement
prenez le cas du passe navigo ou madame
pécresse a changé cinq fois david ans a
fait
on a confiance de mon ami pour faut
rediscuter pourrait changer pour ce nous
et pour certains programmes comme moi
d'abord et après regarder un petit peu
ce qui nous nous verrons si cela se
passe sans ciller les résultats du
référendum donc le du 16 au 18 octobre
et les résultats seront communiqués donc
le dimanche à 20h et nous allons parler
maintenant de la fête de la science à la
commencé hier elle se déroule jusqu'à
dimanche à saint quentin en yvelines et
sur toute la france est un événement
national il ya des ateliers des
manifestations qui sont organisées
alors je me tourne vers vous marie laure
y signa et annabelle doazit que va-t-on
à prendre avec la fête de la science
baroud avant la fête de la science c'est
un million de personnes qui vont
rencontrer cette niche chercheurs donc
effectivement l'objectif c'est de
démocratiser les sciences auprès du
grand public et que chacun puisse avoir
accès à des disciplines qui connaît pas
alors ce qu'on va pour apprendre nous
par exemple on va vous proposer enfin
l'atelier des sciences de saint quentin
en yvelines à la maison de
l'environnement va vous proposer des
ateliers de light painting apprendre à
faire de la peinture avec de la lumière
c'est assez inédit mais je vous engage à
les voir on va aussi proposer à des
enfants d'être sur une banquise
rencontrer un ours et tout ça animé par
des parts des tablettes numériques
vous allez aussi pouvoir essayer de voir
aller grâce à des lunettes infrarouges
l'invisible bon voilà autant de choses
qui sont pour la ville la ville organise
vraiment beaucoup d'ateliers et du côté
de l'observatoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
est ce que le but c'est de montrer aussi
la face cachée des chercheurs ah oui
complètement au 8 août a fait en fait à
l'observatoire on est sur un site qui
est complètement fermée au public qui
n'est absolument pas accessible donc on
essaye dans la mesure du possible deux
fois par an lors des journées du
patrimoine d'une part et lors de la fête
de la science d'autre part de donner à
voir des choses qui sont complètement
fermés et et rendre tout ça public et
essayer de ne susciter quelques
vocations auprès des enfants par exemple
mais aussi de montrer ce qu'on fait au
grand public alors qu'est ce qu'on va
voir justement à l'observatoire que nous
n'avons jamais vu
rien n'est jamais donnée à voir sauf
dans ces situations là cette année on a
une grande nouveauté qui est l'accès au
mur d'image
immersif qui ouvre là cette année pour
le grand public donc c'est un une
liaison d'ordinateur avec un écran géant
qui marchent en 3d avec un système de
trekking donc avec des lunettes 3d et
puis des petites petits capteurs sur les
lunettes on peut être complètement
immergé dans une simulation
ça permet de chercheurs de faire un
travail collaboratif et interactif et on
fait des ateliers pour les petits et les
grands donc voilà tout le monde est très
content vous essayez aussi au niveau de
la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
marie laura et stylia de parler du
numérique des objets connectés c'est
aussi l'ambition de cette année c'est un
moyen d année vers la science exactement
se dire que toute la saison culturelle
2015 2016 a été fondée sur la les arts
numériques effets qui vont pouvoir avoir
accès à des objets connectés des
lunettes oculus rift qui vous projette
dans un monde que vous ne connaissez pas
et avoir accès aussi à des expériences
des manipulations et notamment au centre
commercial aussi qui n'a partenaires
donc le centre saint quentin qui samedi
va accueillir toutes les familles pour
divers ateliers ouverts à tous du côté
de l'observatoire
vous me disiez annabelle doazit excusez
moi que justement les gens aiment bien
venir à la fête de la science parce
qu'ils peuvent se rendre compte du
travail de recherche qui fait en france
où sont mis les font un petit peu voilà
qu'est ce qu'elle arrache en fonction il
voit du côté le côté à cacher on peut
justement où va leur impôt si on peut
tout à fait oui on a cette remarque on a
cette remarque assez régulièrement c'est
assez c'est assez amusant mais déjà on
donne à voir des endroits fermés aux
gens du territoire aux gens de rejoindre
cette commune et des communes alentour
et c'est vrai qu'on a assez
régulièrement cette remarque déjà nous
nous on en fait un petit peu la
promotion entre guillemets parce qu'on
estime que c'est essentiel aussi de
pouvoir montrer au grand public un petit
peu ce qu'on fait d'eux de leurs impôts
si je peux me permettre l'expression et
on a régulièrement cette remarque oui on
a de temps en temps des familles qui
nous disent on paye des impôts mais
quand on voit ça quand on visite a
franchement on est contents alors au
sein de l'observatoire les personnes qui
viennent à visiter donc sont
complètement présenter
il arrive oui je suis un char jouit de
tout le week-end on est ouvert le samedi
pour les enfants de 6 à 12 ans mais ils
sont complètement pris en charge bien
sûr et la journée du dimanche on a
ouvert de 10 heures à 18 heures sans
interruption
donc vous vous rendez à l'observatoire
et à ce moment là on vous accueille en
vous propose un parcours c'est pas du
tout une visite libre j'ai envie de dire
on vous prend en charge on vous propose
des ateliers chacun thomas dialogue à
tout à fait chaque atelier dure 30
minutes donc vous choisissez vraiment ce
que vous voulez faire le temps que vous
voulez visiter
et puis il ya une évidemment les
chercheurs ou les scientifiques ou les
techniciens en fonction des ateliers
sont vraiment là pour faire une vraie
une véritable animation est vraiment
répondre à des questions alors tout il
ya des événements organisés donc tout le
week-end et donc jusqu'à voilà dimanche
s'il ya vraiment un atelier 1 à table
pour la ville et pour lequel serait-il
passé difficile c'est en tout cas pour
les petits et pour les grands noms nains
à tulle et de ballons avec des lâchers
de ballons le mur d'image d'un garage
qui est très dommage une très belle et
oui on a une très belle exposition qui
concerne sam l'instrument qui ont
embarqué à bord du rover curiosity on a
monté une exposition avec avec plusieurs
scientifiques qui sont là pour des
ateliers donc il ya une maquette de
curiosity il ya l'instrument qui a été
en partie fabriqué ici à guyancourt
ça c'est une animation qui a énormément
de succès mais bon je vois là je peux
pas faire le détail mais je pense que
tout vaut le coup très bien et bien
merci à vous merci à vous d'être venu en
plateau nous faisions à la fête de la
science ce week-end nous verrons toutes
ces choses à découvrir mais ce week-end
il n'y a pas seulement la fête de la
science au bourget se tiendra le 15e
salon automédon une exposition d'autos
et de motos de collection avis aux
amateurs parmi les véhicules exposés le
public pour admirer une simca 5 d'un
collectionneur vie sinois à la salle a
créé lui-même son véhicule mais la lipo
qu'elle a rencontrées pour nous regarder
sept mille heures de travail 3500
euros de budget 34 chevaux sous le capot
et le lit que vous l'avez jamais vu
cette simulation berlinette le mans est
le fruit de l'imagination d'alors la
salle
ancien architecte de moteur l'entreprise
automobile française aux chevrons j'en
ai fait je dirais 90% les 10% restants
étant la partie peintures carrosserie
donc s'ils donnent vraiment l'éclat
final à la véhicule
donc ça je les fais avec l'équipe avec
qui je travaillais en concept haut car
c'est la concrétisation d'un rêve ça
c'est aussi très plaisant ils ont
d'arriver à quelque chose de concret
alors que donc on en en arrivait
auparavant tombé amoureux du modèle ah
là là ça se lance dans la conception de
son propre véhicule en 2003 jusqu'en
2011 sa berlinette rendent hommage aux
think accords dits victorieuse aux 24
heures du mans par rapport à l'original
la voiture a été allongée en empattement
pour installer le moteur en position
centrale avant le toit a été descendu de
8 cm de façon à gagner de la place aussi
pour la position du moteur
d'où cet aspect disons beaucoup plus bas
beaucoup plus sportif par rapport à une
simca 5 normal pour l'admirer direction
le salon automédon il se tiendra ce
week-end des 10 et 11 octobre au parc
des expositions du bourget et comme
chaque jeudi les temps de parler sport à
présent avec la chronique sport d'être
journaliste michael elle me d'euros
aujourd'hui nous avons parlé d'une
nouvelle discipline
bonsoir florale a effectivement le fou
de golf est comme son nom l'indiqué un
mélange entre le golf et le football ce
week-end sa discipline s'invite dans le
département la finale nationale 2015
c'est programmé ce samedi au golf des
yvelines vous nous parler de cet
événement nous recevrons sur ce plateau
kevin van est l'un des responsables de
l'événement
alors tout d'abord est ce que vous nous
présentez cette discipline qui est
inconnu du grand public jusqu'à présent
alors tout à fait bon soir inconnu du
grand public voilà c'est une discipline
qui effectivement naissante qui a a été
créée donc en 2009 aux pays bas et qui
tague en france en 2013
donc comme vous l'avez évoqué al ahly
effectivement le football et le golf
donc on est on va dire plus axé sur les
règles du golf en utilisant les outils
du football c'est à dire le shoot et le
ballon mais on est sensiblement voilà
sera une discipline qui se rapproche
vraiment du golfe avec un objectif voilà
pour faire simple qui est de shooter
dans le ballon et de réaliser le moment
de coups possibles par rapport au parent
qui est en fait un score de référence
donc comme comme au ball fait et c'est
un sport qui se veut conviviale avant
tout et que c'est effectivement voilà
très convivial puisque c'est un peu le
on va dire l'ambiance qu'on retrouve sur
nos compétitions avec à la différence
des sports on va dire un peu plus
classique
on part sur un parcours entre 3 et 4
heures donc on a le temps de partage et
d'échangé avec les les adversaires et
les partenaires donc des échanges qui se
veut effectivement voilà base sur la
convivialité et on vient sur nos
compétitions pour pour toute une journée
donc avec tous les à côtés les
animations à la cérémonie de remise des
prix un cocktail donc on est vraiment
sûr sur du bon temps et la prise de
plaisir avant tout qu'ils sont les
maîtres mots de 2 ses disciplines et ce
week-end ce sera très belle affiche
exactement ce week end national la
finale nationale de la fougue cap 2015
donc où seront sacrés le champion de
france le vainqueur de l'afld de la
foudre gold cup et notamment aussi le
club champion de france 2015 donc c'est
le point d'orgue qui voulaient d'une
tournée de treize dates on a parcouru la
france entière toute l'année avec des
compétitions régionales qui voit là dont
les qualifiés se retrouveront pour cette
finale donc au golf des yvelines à deux
pas de vos locaux et votre discipline
est assez récente mais il y aura tout de
même des têtes d'affiché sûres sont au
rendez vous exactement donc tout au long
de l'année on a voilà des pipoles et
d'anciens footballeurs et vétiver
wiltord par exemple un oui dans l'année
dernière effectivement qui voilà qui qui
qui a fait voilà qui nous a accompagnés
tout au long de notre tournée et sur
cette finale notamment on aura des
anciens footballeurs comme l'ancien
lyonnais crise marc libbra bruno cheyrou
ou encore des humoristes comme arnaud
tsamère et la cérémonie de remise de
prix sera animée par karim ziani
voilà qui est une journaliste ma liste
sportif assez connu et le public y est
conviée pour pour cet événement tout à
fait donc c'est une finale effectivement
avec une compétition réservée aux au
qualifié d étape régionale
mais c'est aussi une compétition qui est
ouverte au grand public pour la
participation
mais si également pour pour le spectacle
donc on a de plus en plus de spectateurs
qui viennent sur nos parcours pour
admirer
là les meilleures foules golfeurs
français et européens qui seront
présents justement pour cet événement
qui est pour nous un événement majeur on
en a deux en france voilà au cours de
l'année qui sont l'open de france et la
finale du championnat
donc voilà on aura énormément de deux
personnes attendues de personnalités du
public donc il ya encore voilà des
déplace on va dire des inscriptions qui
peuvent se faire directement sur place
on attend environ voilà entre 180 et 200
personnes sur la compétition et on va
dire entre entre 100 et 200 spectateurs
qui accompagneront les les compétiteurs
sur les greens merci à vous en tout cas
d'être passé sur ce plateau je le
rappelle la compétition de foule goff
est programmée ce samedi à partir de 8
heures au golf des yvelines et en
football on jouera également les 5e tour
de la coupe de france c'est au capital
effectivement florame il y aura le
niveau va encore monter d'un cran après
ce 4e tour le cinquième tour maurepas
qui évolue en division excellence
recevra notamment boulogne billancourt
équipe de ces phases ce dimanche à 14h30
au stade du bout des clos le duel paraît
très déséquilibrée sur le papier la cbb
évolué six divisions au dessus des ide
in one on ne sait jamais avec maurepas
déjà tombeur de torcy au tour précédent
les morts pas un conte une nouvelle fois
sur le soutien du public
ils ont d'ailleurs invité la star
internationale rihanna pour les soutenir
là on va voir tout ouïe ouïe floral vous
avez entendu regarder le tweet horizon
de bompas voilà invité rihanna acceptera
c'est en référence au match psg om ou
rénover avait assisté à la rencontre
voilà c'est ça au clasico donc pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore répondu mais
ont déjà et on passe maintenant à
neauphle qu'il parle qu'il joue aussi en
coupe de france c'est un autre match
qu'il ne faudra pas louper ce week-end
c'est le match de nos fleurons newsflow
recevra drancy une équipe qui évolue en
cfa ce sera très compliqué pour les
yvelinois mille pourront compter sur le
nouveau coach jean luc girard ancien
joueur professionnel au red star avec à
son actif plus de 250 matches de ligue 2
pour les booster pour cette rencontre il
leur apportera son expérience sur ce
type de match ils ont en plus déjà sorti
une cfa au tour précédent avec fleury
mérogis
il ya aussi de la qualité pour les
rohner amical ce week end la ville de
maurepas organise pour la première fois
les foulées de mort pas ce samedi
trois épreuves sont au programme une
course de 6 km une course de 12 km et la
marche nordique de 6 km plus de 200
personnes devraient participer à
l'événement le départ de cette première
édition sera donné à 10 heures au stade
du bout des clos du bois
pardon si vous voulez participer il
reste encore des places pour la
compétition peut s'inscrire une heure
avant le début des épreuves
merci beaucoup michael ou vous retrouver
lundi prochain à 18h30 dans le set hui
sport pour un tarif au complet de ces
rendez vous et nous saurons si rihanna
est venue ou pas assisté au match 2 en
tout cas besoin sans goût moi je serais
je serai là je souhaiterais donc au
match et le sera également pour filmer
pour interviewer les joueurs demain vous
retrouvez wilfried ritchie pour
l'édition du 7 8 le journal du vendredi
moi je vous retrouve lundi à 18 heures
pour une nouvelle édition de ce journal
en direct je vous souhaite donc un très
bon week-end mais aussi une très bonne
soirée
il